はっはっはっはっはっはっはー
はーい　久しぶりだ　みんな
久しぶりだ
なぜ私がしばらく動画に出ていなかったのか
という説明をしよう
実はDr.はじめがでると
動画がかなりの確率で
炎上する
なので今日は
そんなに炎上しなさそうな
実験の動画を撮っていこうと思う
すまん
徹夜の朝６時だ
今日の実験だが
みんなは
というものを使っているだろうか
まぁ　一般的なソファはといえば
こちら
こういうタイプのソファ　よくみかけると思う
まぁ　座り心地もそんな悪くないが
続いてはこちらのソファだ
まぁ　一般的には
あ　いや　まって
まって
まぁ   ふにゃふにゃしてて座り心地はいいんですけども
のっぺりしすぎてて
本当にこれは人として駄目になってしまう
人類の進化を衰退させる可能性がある
非常に危険なソファの一つと認められている
というわけで今日は
今までに無いソファをみなさんに見せようと思う
こちら！
なんと　これがソファになるのです
ちなみに持ち運び可能なソファなので
このままでどこでも持って行ける
ちょっとすぐ作ってみます
えっ　めっちゃ小さいな
もう　こうやってね
どこでもこうやって持ってけるんですよ
ソファを
これでふかふかのソファが作れます
作ってみよう
･･･作成中･･･
巻きます
閉じます
これが新時代のソファ
これ実は空気だけでなん ですけれども
寝れます
お～
っあ　やべぇ
あんなにコンパクトだったやつが
外だったらこうやってね
バタバタして空気を入れるだけで
このソファがどこでもすぐに作れちゃう
超高機能な近未来型なソファーだ
そこで私は思った
この近未来のソファ
この部屋中に置きまくると
最高の快適空間が作りだせるのではないか
ソファというものは
なかなか場所をとってしまうものだ
これ一つにとってもかなり場所をとる
人を駄目にするソファもよく
足に引っかかってうざい
ソファって置くだけでも
結構　場所を取ってしまうが
これはなんと
これくらいの形から
こんな大きくなるので
収納もすごい楽
邪魔となればいつでも片付けることができる
すなわち
大量のエアーソファをここに置きまくっても
なんか　その時は　ちょっと　あの
「すぐ片付けれるっていう」
あの変な安心感があるなか
どれだけ展開してもなんか心になんかその
罪悪感が残らないというか
「ああ　なんかいつでも片付けられるな」
と思ってやってるんで
う～ん　なんか
「まぁ　別にいいんじゃね」
って感じなんですけども
どこを見渡しても
ソファ　ソファ　ソファ
この部屋中をエアーソファで満たす
そして　エアーソファで守られ続けたこの部屋は
どこにどう飛び込んでも
空気の力によって守られ
けがをすることが限りなく
ゼロパーセントに近いと思われる
まさに
今日はそんな神の部屋を作って
私自身が神になろうと思う
では　いこう
あ～
というわけでどんどん作っていきましょう
いくぞ
いっちょ上がり
OK
やっば
この後が楽しみだな
はっはっはっは～
う～ん
はい　というわけで
あるぶん全部　膨らませてみたんですけど
ふー
寝心地が良さそうなのはわかった
だが　息苦しいぞ　これだと
あはは～
どうだ！！
ようやく完成した
これが恐らく
ソファの空間
っはっはっはっはっは～
どうだ魅力的な空間だろ
これなら
どこへ跳んでも気持ちいいし
どこに跳んでもまったく痛くありません
さっそく飛び込んでみましょう
ひゃっほっ～
ダメだ（痛いよ）
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】